ونحييكم مشاهدينا من جديد بين تركيا وسويد
التوتر اهم يميز العلاقات بين البلدين على
خلفيه عدم التزام ستوكهولم بشروط وضعتها
انقره من اجل انضمامها الى حلف شمال
الاطلسي صحيفه فاينل تايمز البريطانيه
اكدت ان مصير انضمام السويد الى الناتو
اصبح عرضه للخطر بعد التظاهر او التظاهر
عفوا التي كانت امام السفاره التركيه في
السويد
والتي تزامنت مع سلسله التظاهرات التي
تشهدها ستوكهولم ضد الرئيس التركي رجب طيب
اردوغان مع قرب الانتخابات التركيه وفقه
مراقبين للتطورات في السويد امام مفترق
الطرق مع تزاوج مطالب انقرابه تسليم
النشطاء الاكراد ومنع التجمعات التي تهاجم
القياده التركييات وهو ما يضع ستوكهولم
طبعا في موقف صعب مع محاولاتها الحصول على
موافقه انقره للانضمام الى الناتو خصوصا
وان الخلاف مع السويد في لندن منح اردوغان
نفوضا غير عاديين على شركاء الغربي
في تحفيظ قاعدته المحافظات قبل الانتخابات
العامه المرتقبه في مايو عندما يواجه حمله
صعبه للاحتفاظ بالسلطه
[موسيقى]
هناك هذا الملف معه ضيوفنا من اسطنبول
معك يا سيد طه في الواقع موقف تركيا
همم
من همم طرح اسماء السويد في لندن همم في
حلف شمال الاطلسي السؤال المطروح الان ما
حسابات تركيا الحاليه للاعتراف بهذا الشكل
في هذا الوقت
تحياتي لكم
اشارتي يعني هناك بعد التوقيع على مذاكره
التفاهم ما بين السويد وفنلندا وتركيا في
حزيران يونيو همم الماضي ما زال العقبات
تراويح مكان وخاصه تتحدث عن ان هناك هواجس
امنيه بالنسبه للجانب التركي لم يعني يتم
الالفا بها حسب تصريحات المسؤوليه الاتراك
هنا تابعنا قبل ايام هناك زياره لوزير
الخارجيه التركي مولود شاوش اوله الى
واشنطن وهذه الزياره على رغم انها كانت هي
مهمه للغايه على سعيد علاقات التركيه
الامريكيه والحديث عن موضوع مقاتلات السته
عشر لكن تم ربط هذه الزياره وعضويه فنلندا
السويد بمعنى هناك مقايده امريكيه في هذا
همم الموضوع لسه انقل تعي ذلك تماما وتؤكد
بان اعتقد هنا الفرصه مناسبه همم لها خاصه
تتحدثنا عن ان تلك الدول اقصد في لندن
وايد هما قامت بحظر السلاح لانقره في
الحرب تشنتها في سوريا في عام 2019 هناك
مطلوبين امنيا كما تقول انقره انقره تؤكد
بانها هي دوله كبيره في حلفان قديمه من
مؤسسها الحلف ويجب على تلك الدول ان يعني
ان تقوم بتبديد المخاوف في تركيا تحدثنا
عن موقف التركي بشكل عام من عمليه
الانضمام انا التصور واعتقد هناك لا توجد
مشكله
لانضمامه لا بالعكس هناك تصريحات تركيا
تؤكد انضمام تلك الدولتين هو تزيدان هذا
الحلف قوته ولكن هناك في اجانب الاخر هناك
زاويه اخرى مهمه للغايه هناك خطط امريكيه
الانضمام وهو يكتب الخطط الامريكيه لتضيق
على روسيا لكن تركيا هي تلقفت هذا هذه
يعني الفكره الامريكيه او ال- ال- النوايا
الامريكيه وهي تريد همم ان تترجمها وفق
مصالحها الخاصه
هذا التحالف تركي الروسي ولكن لان اقف على
مجموعه النقاط التي حددتها منذ قليل
وانقلها لضيف السيد اندريسات اندري هل
تتفق مع ضيفي على ان حسابات اردوغان
الحاليه هي مواقف السويد في لندن السابقه
فتره الحرب على سوريا همم مواقف تخص كما
قال اردوغان بان هذه الدول باتت بيوتا
لاستقبال المنظمات الارهابيه نتحدث على
عناصر من عمال همم الكردستاني وكذلك جماعه
جولين او كما يقول مراقبون الوضع يخص
الانتخابات الداخليه وهذه هي اولويه
الرئيسه التركي
مساء الخير اولا وصحيح ما قاله ضيفك
الكريم من انقر عن الجوانب المتعلقه
بمخاوف تركيا وبالعلاقه مع الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه ولكن اردوغان وهو مفاوض
زكي ويعرف كيف يستغل الامور اين ذلك من
خلال ازمه مثلا المهاجرين مع الاتحاد
الاوروبي وكيف حصل على المليارات الان يجد
ان الفرصه مناسبه لذلك ولكن تحركه بالنسبه
للانضمام البلدين المذكورين الى الحلف
الاطلسي لا ينحصر فقط بهذه الزاويه انما
ياتي من ضمن استراتيجيه اوسع همم بالنسبه
لاردوغان بالنسبه لملفات اقليميه كما ذكرت
في سوريا هناك كان محاولات لمعالجه الوضع
في سوريا كان هناك وساطه من قبل روسيه
للتقارب بين تركيا وسوريا الرئيس اردوغان
لا يريد ان يزعج تركي روسيه كثيره ولا ان
يتجه ان يسير في همم
مع انه مع او عفوا مع انه يزود اوكرانيا
بالسلاح هناك ايضا هذا الشعور بالعداء
الذي يشعر اردوغان بانه يتنامى في بعض
الدول ضده راينا مثلا في السويد كيف تم
حرق دميه تمثل رئيس اردوغان بسبب مواقفه
الاخيره موضوع الاكراد ايضا موضوع مهم
ولكن من نقاط
ما يهمني هو راي حضرتك
من بين كل هذه النقاط وهي في الواقعه
عديده جدا وكلها تشكل ال- ال- الموقف
الاساسي التركي
في هذه المرحله بالذات هل اردوغان يمثل
يفكر في كل هذه النقاط او يفكر في
الانتخابات القادمه في مايو
موضوع الانتخابات هو جزء فصل كما ذكرت
هناك استراتيجيه متكامله حتى بالنسبه
لعلاقات مع دول الجوار موضوع الانتخابات
طبعا راينا ان اردوغان اليوم
يتصدر الواجهه وجهه السياسه على ساحه
الخارجيه من خلال عده ملفات ليست فقط
انضمام السويد وفولندا هذه جزء منها يريد
ان يقول بانه هو المدافع الاول عن امن
البلاد عن الامن القومي التركي من خلال
مواجهه حزب العمال الكردستاني اثنين بانه
ايضا يدافع عن صوره تركيا كقوه رائده في
المنطقه ومن بين الدول الرائده على الصعيد
العلاقات مع دول الغرب وهو ايضا لا يرد
داخل الابتزاز ولا يريد ان يكون ايضا هذا
ما يحاول ان يعطيه صوره في السياسه
الخارجيه تابع لاي دوله على الاخلاص
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه في موضوع
الاستغلال الداخلي طبعا اردوغان اعتقد
الضيف يوافق ربما مواجهه بعض الصعوبات في
الداخل في المده الاخيره استطلاعات ايه
يعني ليست مريحه بالنسبه اليه هناك حتى من
داخل حزبه بعض التساؤلات عن ترشحي مره
جديده وعن امكانيه كسب هذه الانتخابات اذا
هذه ورقه يرفعها في وجه داخل وجاء اعضاء
حزبه ومؤيدين درجه اولى
بكل صراحه
ومصداقيه همم هل الموقف واطرح نفس السؤال
على حظرتك هل اردوغان يفكر يعني خلينا
نفكر كما يفكر رئيس التركي هل اولوياته هي
الانتخابات في مايو لان الحرب الروسيه
الاوكرانيه لا نعلم همم ما مدى استمرار
وحسابات التسليح وحسابات همم يعني وجود من
يعتبرهم اردوغان من قناه ارهابيه هذا
الموضوع قديم حالي ويمكن ان يستمر ولكن
الجديد هو الانتخابات بشفافيه هل انتخابات
تعني اردوغان وتدفعه للضغط على ملف السويد
يعني يعني هذا الموضوع موضوع مهم جدا نعم
خاصه بالنسبه للرئيس اردوغان هذا
الانتخابات القادمه المقبله هي تختلف عن
باقي الانتخابات السابقه نتحدث عن هناك
تحالف معارض قوي جدا يحاول سحب البساط
البساط من تحت اقدام الرئيس اردوغان كما
ذكر ضيفي كان رئيس اردوغان دا من هو مناور
زكي وقوي ويستغل كل الظروف واعتقد اولئك
ظروف منحت او منحت له خلال الفتره الاخيره
الماضيه بدايه من حرب روسيه الاوكرانيه
استغلها بشكل كبير ونجحها فيما يتعلق
بازمه الحبوب هناك انا من وجهه نظر اعتقد
الاسماء هي لا تتعدى فقط تركيا والسويد
وفنلندا تتعدى هي اكبر من ذلك واقصد تركيا
رئيس المتحده الامريكيه اشارتك بدايه
حديثه زياره
تماما بان المشكله المشكله والحل هي في
همم الولايات المتحده الامريكيه لذا هي
توجه رساله العبره همم انتقاداتها للسويد
في متعلق بالمطلوبين المقصود بعمان الثاني
وتظاهرات وهي تعي تماما تحت امريكيه هي
التي تدعم قوات قصد في سوريا هي التي
تستضيف فتح الله الجولان المتهم الاول في
المحاوله انقلابيه لذا ااا كل هذه الامور
يعني تخدم تركيا بشكل كبير وتختم من دون
شك الحزب الحاكم رئيس اردوغان المقبل بعد
الشرطي
صحيح ولكن قد يقول البعض ولو ان الملف ليس
ملف ناقد يقول بعض بانه اردوغان كذلك في
فتره من الفترات همم سما حال الاخوان بان
يكونوا على الارض التركي وفي نفس هذا
الوقت مبدا يده لمصالحه مع مصر فلماذا
اردوغان لا يقبل من غيره ما يقبله لنفسه
يعني موضوع يعني الحزب العمال الكردستاني
وخاصه هذا تعلمين انه هو من خطوط الحمراء
بالنسبه لتركيا وكما ذكر ضيف هذا موضوع
قديم يعني منذ سنوات موجوده هذه المنظمه
في الدول الاوروبيه ولكن في الفتره
الاخيره هناك محاولات استفزازيه من تلك
الدول واذا سمحت لي يعني فيما يتعلق ب-
لماذا هذا التحرك والخطوات الاخيره من قبل
السويد في الفتره الاخيره
الدخول الى حلف همم
ناته بسبب هناك خطط امريكيه همم لمحاصره
وتضييق على روسيا خلال المرحله المقبله
الدوله المنتميه للحلف والتي تعارض وترفع
حق الفيتو لتدخل اي دوله كانت فهي تقضي
على حلمها هل تعتقد بانه اردوغان سيستمر
في الضغط ولكن خلاصه القول هو منع السويد
كليا من الانضمام او ان مجال القبول
المفتوح
لا طبعا المجال مفتوح هناك مفاوضات سوف
تستمر قد ياخذ الامر بعد الوقت لانه كما
ذكرنا موقف اردوغان ليس موقف مبدئي معارض
لانضمام البلدين وتحديدا السويد هو كان
وافق على بروتوكول الانضمام قبل عده اشهر
قليله يبقى ان توافق جميع الدول كانت
المجر وتركيا اخر دولتين الان يريد ان
يقايد هذه الموافقه سوف يا مدلل الموافقه
هو نفسه الذي قال قبل مده بان انضمام دول
البلطيق بالعكس هو عنصر قوه للواء حلف
شمال الاطلسي وقد تفيد ايضا تركيا هو يريد
ان يفاوض على موضوع الاكراد كما ذكرنا هو
يتهم بالدرجه الاولى يعني السويد بانها لم
تطبق الاتفاقيه الموقعه حول قرار يعني
المقايضه بين موافقتها على الانضمام
وتسليمه عدد من عناصر حزب العمال
الكردستاني اعتقد حوالي 140 شخص كانت تم
الاتفاق على ذلك موافقته على الدخول الى
الاطلسي
بنى السويد لن توافق اذا وافقت سوف هو
ايضا ياتي موافقه بالمقابل اثنين لديه
ايضا بعض الشروط مع الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه هو يريد ان يقيم التوازن بل
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه وروسيا لا
يريد ان ياخذ موقف يعني صارم بين احدى
الدولتين يريد ان نسينا السيد ولكن صحيح
جدا بالنسبه لروسيا وتركيا تحدثت في
السابق وقالت لاننا ليس هذه الدرجه اها
ليس لهذه الدرجه اقول لماذا اولا السويد
ليست قوه اساسيه قد تكون ربما تشكل من
الناحيه الجغرافيه ارضيه لتمدد الحلف
الاطلسي او للنشر سلاح للحلف الاطلسي في
هذه الدوله نعم اه اه اه الرئيس الروسي
قال بانه لا يعارض بالمطلق ولكن اذا تم
وضع او نشر اسلحه للاطلس في هذان بلدين
عندها سوف يرد بالشكل المناسب فلندا ربما
قد تكون موقعها اقوى من السويد يجب ان
نعرف ان فلندا لديها مساحه مشتركه او حدود
مع روسيه حوالي 1300 كيلو متر هي تستطيع
في حاله تعبئه ان تجيش 900,000 جندي وهي
تدرب سنويا 28,000 جندي فنلندا بين السويد
كل عناصر الجيش
السويد 62,000 المشكله الاساسيه انه
بالنسبه
الروسيه ايضا تريد بعض التطبيقات بان هذه
الاراضي التي تنضم والدول البطيخ بشكل عام
يعني انضمت بعد دول اوروبا الشرقيه
ولم يزعج بوتين كثيرا ان تكون هناك ضمانات
بانها لن تكون ارضيه للانطلاق باي اعتداء
على روسيا طبعا هي مهمه بالنسبه للولايات
المتحده الامريكيه من ناحيه الاستخبارات
سوف تكون على مقربه من الحدود الروسيه
ولكن ايضا بوتين هدد بانه سوف ينشر اسلحه
على الحدود اردوغان يريد ايضا مع روسيا ان
يبقي على الاتفاق ان يكون ممرا لنقل النفط
غير الحبوب الذي ذكره ضيفك الكريم من
اسطنبول هناك مشروع ايضا او قضيه نقل
الغاز او الطاقه الروسيه عبر تركيا وان
كان بشكل عقبات للجميع مصلحه مشتركه الان
كيف يتم التفاوض على مجالات مصالح كل
الاطراف سوف تنتهي الى العملي
سؤال وباختصار لو سمحت لي سيد طه مع كل ما
اتينا عليه هو يتحدثنا فيه عن هذه الملفات
الضغط والحسابات كل دوله همم ثنائيه تركيا
همم الولايات المتحده الامريكيه من الدوله
التي تمتلك اكثر ملفات قدره ان تضغط بها
على طرف الاخر واشنطن ام انقره
او اوراق تركيه قويه جدا وخاصه في نتحدثنا
في هذا الملف هو خاصه فيما يتعلق في
علاقتها مع روسيا لكن هناك ملف اخر وهو
ملف يعني مقاتلات السته عشر متحده
الامريكيه تبقى يعني هي القوه التي ممكن
ان تحرك يعني همم الاوراق من جديد خاصه ان
انقر حاليا كما اشارتك مقبله بعد اشهر
القليله على انتخابات لا تريد ان تخطئ
حساباتها دقيقه جدا يعني خاصه تعاملها مع
روسيا من جهه وتعاملها معروف المتحده
الامريكيه اذا حتى هذه اللحظه الثقف عالي
جدا من قبل همم انقره تريد تحصيل مكاسب
وهذه المكاسب ان تترجم على ارض الواقع
وخاصه تسجل لان نقاط لرئيس اردوغان في
انتخابات القادمه
لا اقول انه قد يتسلح طبعا سلاح ولا اف 35
ايضا لا ننسى ان تركيا تحتضن قاعده
امريكيه مهمه انجليك يعني لن يصل الامر
الى حد الانفصال ولكن نقطه صغيره الرئيس
اردوغان الان لا يريد ان يعطي الموافقه
مقابل لا شيء هو ربما يكون استخرج العبر
من اعاده انضمام جارته اليونان الى الحلف
الاطلسي بعد انسحابه بعد حرب 74 وافقه
اردوغان من دون اي مقابل الان يريد مقابل
ليس اكثر كيف سيتم التفاوض ما هو الثمن
هذا ستظهر له الايام المقبله على كل حال
الاطلسي وفنلندا لم تستبعد السماء
بالعكس اهلا وسهلا بك
شكرا جزيلا على الحضور همم من اسطنبول طه
عوده كاتب هو المحل السياسي ومن باريس
الكاتب المحلله السياسي شكرا جزيلا